اذا نعود الان للصور المباشره التي تصلنا
من صنعاء رفضا للحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع
غزه وتضامنا مع
الفلسطينيين تشهد مدن يمنيه عده ايضا
مظاهرات تضامن مع الفلسطينيين منها
الحديده
وتعس هذه الصور مباشره من صنعاء ويظهر
فيها اعداد كبيره من
المشاركين
الفخ اليوم سيرات مليونيه ليؤكد على ما
يلي اولا اهميه الاستمرار دون كلل ولا ملل
ولا تراجع ولا انكسار في انشطته الشعبيه
والرسميه والسياسيه والاعلاميه والتعبئه
الجهاديه وبعمليات العسكريه المستمره بكل
الامكانيات الم هذه المظاهرات التي
تكم
عاء وحدها وانما تنتشر في مدن اخرى في
اليمن مثل الحديده وتعز
وهي تخرج نصره لاهالي غزه ومطالبه بوقف
الحرب اذا هذه جوانب من الاعداد الكبيره
التي خرجت اليوم الجمعه رغم الظروف الجويه
تساقط الامطار والتي قدر مراسلنا قبل قليل
بان
الاعداد في اعداد العشرات عشرات الالاف
ولكن طبعا لا نستطيع تقدير هذه الاعداد
الصور
تظهر عدد كبير
من
المشاركين ايضا ننوه بهذا الخبر نقلا عن
شركه ميرسك للشحن البحري بان هناك تعليق
مؤقت لحجوزات الشحن بين الشر والغرب عبر
البحر الاحمر وذلك بسبب تقلب الوضع كما
ذكرت
الشركه الاحمر ولعل ما نشاهده الان على
الشاشه مرتبط بشكل كبير باعتبار ان جماعه
انصار الله
الحوثيين هم ان شنوا حمله على هذه
السفن استهدفوا عدد كبير
منها يتم استهدافه فقط السفن المتجهه الى
اسرائيل او التي تكون لها اي علاقه
باسرائيل
ونتابع معكم اذا هذه الصور مظاهرات كبيره
رغم الامطار التي تتساقط في صنعاء حاليا
ولكن هذا لا يمنع على ما يبدو المتظاهرين
من الخروج
نصره لشعب الفلسطيني في
غزه
على صنعاء وانما تنتشر في مدن يمنيه اخرى
مثل الحديده
وتعس